yeah it's crazy it's like you having a
like in a moment I was gonna use the
word Epiphany but then that pulls from
Rolo so I don't know it's a whole
different meaning but it's crazy that
you like you have a moment where you're
if you're willing to kind of sit back
and like think you're like oh that
makes sense that's why I love I I red
pilled my friend for the first time like
that's one of my favorite series I've
been doing less of them lately
but you can only do so much I've been
traveling but but um I that's my
favorite series I've done on my channel
because you can just see the wheels
turning like on these girls like for the
first time like and they're even further
back than me where you're talking about
like the pay Gap but when you explain
the pay Gap to girls that have always
believed there's a pay Gap it's like you
see the wheels turning and they're like
oh so that's not real